ก็
สวัสดีค่ะพี่อาร์ตี้สวัสดีครับน้องเรียม
สวัสดีทำนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนว้าว
มันเจอกันอีกแล้วเจอกับพี่อาตี้แล้วก็
น้องเตรียมในช่องคอม renzo ไทยไทยค่ะโอเค
วันนี้วันนี้เรามาเจอกันวันให้ครับวันนี้
วันนี้วันอังคารค่ะวันนี้วันอังคารใช่ไหม
ครับขอวันอังคารไหนๆอ้อวันอังคารอยู่นี่
วันอังคารวันนี้วันอังคารวันที่เท่าไหร่
ครับวันที่
21 ค่ะอ๋อวันอังคารวันที่ 21  ka วันนี้
วันอังคารแล้วเมื่อวานเมื่อวานวันอะไร
ครับเมื่อวานวันจันทร์หมอเมื่อวานวัน
จันทร์โอเคอ่ะเมื่อวานวันจันทร์แล้วพรุ่ง
นี้พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรครับพรุ่งอ่าวันพุธขอ
พรุ่งนี้วันพุธโอเควันนี้วันอังคารที่ 21
แล้วเมื่อวานเมื่อวานวันที่เท่าไหร่ครับ
เมื่อวานวันที่ 20 ค่ะอ๋ออ๋อเมื่อวานวัน
ที่ 25 แล้วอ้วนนี้วันที่ 21 แล้วพรุ่ง
นี้พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรครับพรุ่งนี้วันวัน
หรือวันที่คะฮ่าๆๆ OK พรุ่งนี้วันที่เท่า
ไหร่ครับ
พรุ่งนี้วันที่ 22 ค่ะอ๋ออ๋อพรุ่งนี้วัน
ที่ 22 โอเคโอเคๆแล้วเดือนนี้เดือนนี้
เดือนอะไรครับเดือนนี้ธันวาคม 5 เดือนนี้
เดือนธันวาคมปีพศอะไรครับขอสไตส์แต่คศ
21  5 คออะ
2021 หน้าโอเคครับแล้วปีพศอะไรครับพ.ศ
2506  14 ค่ะเออ
2564 โอเคโอเคๆแล้วโอเคตอนนี้อ่าตอนนี้
กี่โมงแล้วครับกี่โมงนี้
เตรียมดูนาฬิกา
ตอนนี้
9:00 น 15 น 9 โมง 15
หน้า 9 โมง 15 นาทีนหาออตอนเช้าใช่ไหม
ครับโอเค
9:15 นาทีอ่ะโอเคอ่าวันนี้วันนี้ตาเจ๊
ติ๊กคิดว่าเราจะมาเรียนเกี่ยวกับตัวเลข
กันครับ
ตัวเลขใช่ครับ 1  2  145 ไทยครับตัวเลข
ตัวเลข
ใช่ครับ
หน้าเกี่ยวกับตัวเลขแบบนักเรียนรู้จักตัว
เลขเท่าไรบ้างครับ
ที่หาญ
ครับตอนนี้เห็น
5 ตัวนี้แลกอะไรครับหนึ่ง
หาแค่แล้วต่อไปเลขอะไรครับ
R33 เลยครับอ่านิ
ครับ 6  5 โอเคเดี๋ยวพี่เขียนให้เขียนให้
ถึงแรก
หา
แต่ 8
มีอาการท่อเล็กสุดท้ายอยู่ตรงนี้ครับเลข
15 ใช้ครับเลข 10 ขอแค่อ่าเดี๋ยวเราไป
ฝึกฝึกนิดหน่อยฝึกนิดหน่อยพ่อเราต้องฝึก
ก่อนเดี๋ยวพี่จะมีเกมให้เล่นมีเกมให้เล่น
นะครับน้าหาเล่นเกมหน้าๆน้องเรียมชอบเล่น
เกมไหมครับชอบ
5 ชอบโอเควันนี้เราเล่นเกมเกี่ยวกับตัว
เลข
นะครับ 5 เดี๋ยวดูตรงนี้ก่อนในรูปรูปแรก
รูปแรกรูปนี้ครับ
อ่ามี
อะไรอยู่ในนี้ครับที่น้องเรียนเห็นมิ
เรียมเห็นพวงหรีด Christmas
หน้านี่พวงหรีดใช่ไหมหน้าเป็นพวงหรีดก็มี
พวงหรีดกี่พวงครับมีพวงหรีดคริสต์มาส 3
ควงค่ะอ้าวหนึ่งสองสามมิตร 3 ควงอ่างั้น
น้องเรียมหาเลข 3 เลข 3 อยู่ไหนครับ
เลข 3
อยู่ข้างขวา
คะ
การซ้ายหรือตรงกลางอ่ะใช่ครับอยู่ตรงไหน
ครับเลข 3
อยู่ข้างที่
นั่งขวาโอเคอ้าต่อไปครับอ่าซ้อมก่อนนี้
ให้น้องเรียนฝึกฝึกหาตัวเลขนะครับหน้า
เดี๋ยวจะไปเล่นเกมต่อไปอันนี้เป็นอะไร
ครับเป็นถุงเท้า
ถุงเท้าถุงเท้ามีกี่ข้างครับมี 4 ข้าง
หน้า 1  2  3  4 มี 4 ข้างๆแล้วเลข 4 ก็
ถุงเท้าทั้งสี่ข้างก็ให้หาหาเลข 4 เลข 4
อยู่ตรงไหนครับอยู่ซ้ายมือซ้ายมือคืออ่า
นี่เลข 4 อยู่ซ้ายมือโอเคต่อไปครับปรับ
อาญารูปจะไปรูปนี้ครับรูปซันตาครอส
ซานตาคลอสมีซันตาครอสกี่คนครับมี 5 คนค่ะ
5 มี 5 คนนะครับอ้าก็หาหาเลข 51 นี้ข้า
ไม่ฆ่าอยู่ไหนครับอยู่ตรงกลางขออยู่ตรง
กลาง
ว้าวเก่งจังเลยนะครับต่อไปฮ่าๆรูปสุดท้าย
ครับอันนี้เป็นอภัยครับ
อะไรคะ 21 เอวคนเอวเป็นเป็นผู้ช่วยของ
ซันตาคอสช่วยสันตาคอสค่าหอหมอของขวัญห่า
ๆใช่เขาเป็นเอวอย่างเป็นเอวยังก็ต้องขอ
ของขวัญป้ายออกของขวัญให้ซันตาครอสเอาของ
ขวัญไปแจกเด็กๆอ๋อโอเคแม่มีเอวกี่คนครับ
มี 6 คนค่ะ 5 มี 6 คนอ้านักเรียนเอ้อน้อง
เรียมหาหารเลข 6 เลข 6 อยู่ไหนครับเลข 6
อยู่ขวามืออยู่ขวามือโอเคเลข 6 อยู่นี่
อ่าอ่ะ
ตอนนี้พร้อมพร้อมที่จะไปและเล่นเกมหรือ
ยังครับนักเรียนพร้อมเล่นเกมพร้อมไหมครับ
พร้อมไหมครับหน้าไปหาแล้วเล่นเกมส์หาตัว
เลขนะเจ๊พร้อมและอาไปกันไปกันไปเล่นเกม 5
โอเคอ่ามี
แกมีรูปอยู่ทั้งหมด
กี่แถวครับ 1  2  3
4  5 มี 4 แถวอามิสซีแถวแถวที่ 1 แถวที่
2 แถวที่ 3 แถวที่ 4 โอเคมี 4 แถวนะครับ
อ่ะกติกานะครับก็คือเดี๋ยวให้น้องเรียน
เปิดเปิดเปิดสองรูปสองรูปเพื่อหาหาตัวเลข
นะครับล่าโอเคอะเดี๋ยวให้น้องเรียมเริ่ม
เลือกครับ
จะเอารูปก็เดี๋ยวนะอ้ามันจะมีรูปที่อยู่
และขวา
ด้านซ้ายแล้วก็ตรงกลางใช่ไหมครับใช่ห่าหา
ขวาก็ได้นะคะเดี๋ยวพี่อาร์ตี้จะเขียนไว้
ให้ก่อนว่าตรงไหนที่เป็นด้านขวา
ด้านสายอานิตรงกลางตรงกลางโอ๋โอเคโอเค
โอเคๆ
5 เลือกได้เลยครับน้าเรียม
เงือกแถวที่ 1 จะเปิดเปิดแถวที่ 1 อารูป
กลางตรงกลางโอเคแถวที่ 1 ตรงกลางเปียตี้
เปิด
ป้าโอ้วันนี้นี่รูปมีอะไรครับรูปผ้าพันคอ
อ๋ออ๋อเป็นผ้าพันคออะเกะอะมีผ้าพันคอกี่
ผืนครับ
ผ้าพันคอ 2 ผืน 2 ผืนอ่าน 1 ผืน 2 ผืนมี
ผ้าพันคอ 2 ผืนน้องเรียมต้องหาหา
แลกเลข 2 ใต้ครับอ่ะเลข 2 อยู่ตรงไหนครับ
เลี้ยงเลือกแถวที่สองแถวที่สองอ่า
ตายหมู่
สายมือลูบนี้อ่าเดี๋ยวพี่จะเปิดตาแล้วเรา
ดูว่าจะเป็นเลข 2 ไหมเลข 2 ไหมโอเคนะครับ
อ่าเปียตีเปิดแล้วนะเปิดแล้วนะเปิดแล้วนะ
เฮ้อเปิดแล้วนะเปิดธาดามาฮ่าๆๆไม่ใช่เลข 2
อะเบี้ยติ๊บปิดปิดก่อนปิดเกาะเรียงเห็น
เลียมเห็นอะไรครับฮ่าๆๆก็มีกล้วยที่เห็น
นะมีกล้วยด้วยนะฮ่ะเดี๋ยวอ้าอันนี้นิรูป
กล้วยใช่ไหมครับอ๋ออ๋อมีกล้วยกล้วยอ่ากี่
หนหน้ากล้วย 6 ผลใช่ไหม 1  2  3  4  5  6
อามีกล้วย 6 ผลโอเคโอเคโอเคมีกล้วย 6 ฝน
อ่ะโอเคอ่าน้องเรียมเลือกใหม่ครับเลือก
ใหม่น้า
แถวที่ 1 ขวามือแถวที่ 1 ขวามืออันนี้อ้า
เฮียตี้เปิดนะ
ขวามือกับพี่โอเค
ขวามืออ่ะ
อาเฮียที่ประเสริฐนะครับเปิดแล้วเป็นเลข
เลขอะไรครับเลข 5  5k เลข 5 อยู่ตรงนี้
อยู่ตรงนี้อ้าน้องเรียมเลือกอีก 1 รูป
ครับเลือกอีก 1 รูป
แถวที่ 3 แถวที่ 3 อาแถวที่ 3 อยู่ขวามือ
โอเคตรงนี้นี่ครับพี่เปิดเปิดแล้วนะจะ
เป็นเลข 5 หรือเปล่านะเล่นหาด่าออก
[ปรบมือ]
มาให้ให้ได้
เตรียมจังจำอะไรได้ครับกล้วย 6 ผลหอรวย 6
ผลอยู่ตรงไหนอ่ะเดี๋ยวให้น้องเรียมเลือก
คำสั่งก็เตรียมเลือกแถวที่สองแถวที่ 2 นะ
แถวนี้แถวนี้อยู่ซ้ายหรืออยู่ขวาครับซ้าย
มือซ้ายมือรูปนี้อะเพียงตี้เปิด
อ้อนก็มีกล้วยย6ผลใช่ไหมโอเคห้วยหกผลอยู่
ตรงนี้แล้วน้องเรียมอยากเปิดตรงไหนอีก
ครับแถวที่ 3 แถวที่สาวขวามือขวามืออยู่
ตรงนี้หรืออยู่ตรงนี้ครับได้
อ๋อขวามืออยู่ตรงนี้ใช่ค่ะขวามือตรงนี้
อ้าเบียร์ที่จะเปิดรูปนี้นะครับเปิดแล้ว
นะเฟอร์เฮ้ย
เฮ้ยค่ะพี่เรียม
อย่าหากรู้ไหมอยากรู้เปิด
ขอเบอร์จ 1  2  3 เย้
เลข 6 ใช่ไหมหน้าเป็นแรก 6 แล้วก็มีกล้วย
6 ผลถูกต้องถูกต้องนะครับโอเค
อ่ะป้าอยากให้นักเรียนเลือกอีก 2 รูปนาน
เลือกตรงไหนครับ
แถวที่ 4
แถวที่ 4 นะนะครับผมตรงกลางตรงกลางตรง
กลางแถวที่ 4 รูปหมีเฮียตี้เปิด
เปิดแล้วนี้เป็นอะไรครับเป็นเป็นอะไรครับ
ทั้งสีฟัน 5 แปลงสีฟันแปรงสีฟันกูเยอะมาก
ๆ
แพ็ค 10 อันเยอะเลยพี่แป้ง 10 ท่านที่อัน
ครับ
1  2 บาท 4  4  5  5  6  7  8  9  10  5
9 แปรงสีฟัน 9 อันนี้นี่หน้าแปรงสีพัน
เก้านะน้องเรียมก็ต้องหาเลขอะไรครับเลข 9
เลข 9  KR เลข 9 อยู่ตรงไหนครับอา
แถวที่
2 เอาที่ 2 โอเคเออขวามืออ่ะรูปนี้อ่ะ
ตี้จะเปิดจะเปิดแล้วนะเปิดแล้วนะครับเปิด
แถวที่ 2 ขวามือครับว่าเป็นเล็ก 9 ไหม
เล็ก 9 ไหมนะครับอ่ะเปิดแล้วนะเปิดแล้วนะ
ครับเปิดเลยนะ
เปิดเลยเฮ้ยหาด่าไม่ใช่มั้ยเฮ้ยๆๆๆ
เล่นเพลงให้หมดแล้วเนี่ย
อ๋อโอเคเรียงเห็นโรงเรียนหน้ามีร่มใช่
ครับรมสามัญ
ami ร่อม
นะอ้าเดี๋ยวตีให้นักเรียนดูชัดๆก่อนอ่า
นี่ครับมีอะไรรูปนี้ไม่ใช่เลข 9 ไม่ใช่
เลข 9 มันคือร่มนามิร่มกี่คันครับ 3 คัน 3
คันอ่าน 1  2  3 อ่ามีร่ม 3 คันในรูปนี้
ครับโอเคอ้าให้นักเรียนมเลือก
เลือกแถวที่ 1 สายแถวที่ 1 ซ้ายมือใช่ไหม
ซ้ายมือใช้เงินนิเปิดเลยเปิดเปิดเร็วๆสิ
น่ะ
อันนี้อะไรครับเนี่ยนะอะไรอ่ะและนี่คือ
อะไรหนูเตรียมบอกนักเรียนหน่อยขอเป็นหมวก
หมวกอ่ะโอเคอ้ามีหมวกกี่ใบครับ
เตรียมเห็นมีหมวก 8 ใบอ่า 1  2  3  4  5
6  7  8  5 มีหมวก 8 ใบน้องเรียนต้องหา
หาเลขอะไรครับ
เล็ก 8 อยู่ตรงไหนเลข 8 อยู่ตรงไหนครับ
อ้ออ้อ
ฮ่า
ๆๆ
เร็วๆแล้ว
แถวที่ 2 แถวนี้ต่อเวลาจะหมดๆครับเอาตรง
ด้านซ้ายหรือตรงกลางตรงกลางนะ
ไม่ใช่นี้แลกอะไรครับเลขจ้างเลข 9 ไม่ใช่
อ่ะกิ๊บปิดก่อนปิดแต่ก่อนเตรียมเลือกแถว
ที่ 4 ตรงกันฮ่าๆๆน้องเรียมจำได้แล้วนะจำ
ได้ว่ามีมีอะไรอยู่ตรงนี้มีแปลงอยู่ 9
อันจะได้โอเคกับรูปไหนครับเลิกรูปนี้กับ
รูปไหนแถวที่ 2 ตรงกลางตรงกลางอ๋อนะฮ่าๆ
เป็นเลข 9 โรงเรียมจำได้ครับเครียดพี่ก็
จำได้ไงว่ามีเลข 9 อยู่ตรงนี้ต่อไปครับ
ต่อไปแถวที่ 3 ตรงกลางแถวที่ 3 แถวนี้
แล้วที่ 3 ตรงปางน่ะเฮียตี้เปิดก่อนอ้า
เป็นเลข 8 เป็นเล็ก 8 อ่านักเรียนต้องหา
หาอะไร 888 บาทได้ไหมคะมีเพี้ยนติ๊ก 800
ต่อมด่าทำได้อยู่ตรงไหนครับพี่มีค่ะ
แถวที่ 1 สายมีลายมือหรือฝ่ามืออันนี้
ซ้ายมือขวามืออ้าอยู่ซ้ายมือนะพี่ติ๊ก
เปิดแล้วนะเปิดเลยเปิดเปิดหา
ด่าๆมีหมวก 8 ใบคู่กับเล็ก 8 ถูกต้องครับ
โอเคต่อไปต่อไปต่อไปเตรียมเลือกแถวที่ 3
แถวที่ 3 อ่าแถวนี้อะซ้ายมือ
หมอเป็นเลขเลขอะไรครับเลขหายหน้าต่อไปเอา
รูปไหนดีครับเอาแถวที่สองแถวที่ 2
คือ
ตัวตีจำได้
ไปตีเปิดแล้วนะถูกมั้ยหัวน้องเมียม 7 ตำ
ได้ไหมว่าให้รึอาอ้าใช่หรือเปล่า
ท้าดาถูกต้องครับเป็นร่อม 3 คันหน้ารม 3
คันคู่กับเลข 3 ถูกต้องครับอ่ะต่อไปต่อไป
ก็เปิด
แถวที่ 4 ค่ะแถวที่ 4
ขวามือนิซ้ายมืออันนี้ขวามือเพชรอิสเปิด
ก่อน
อ้าวแบนแรก
2 นะฮะจำได้ไหมนักเรียนนักเรียนจำได้ไหม
ครับเลข 2 อยู่ตรงไหนอยู่ตรงไหน
เลข 2 เรียมจำได้
เมียตีกันจะไปถ่ายกับ R พันคออยู่ตรงไหน
ครับอยู่แถวที่ 1 แถวที่ 1 อ๋อต้องปางนะ
พี่เปิดแล้วนะเปิดหรืออยู่ด้านขวาไม่ใช่
อยู่ตรงกลาง
ถ้าไม่ใช่อยู่ตรงกลางใช่ไหมโอเคเปิดแล้ว
นะครับ 1
ช้าด่าฮ่าๆ
มีผ้าพันคอ
2 ผืนหน้าคู่กับแรก 2 ถูกต้องนะครับเย้
เย้เย 5 รูปสุดท้ายเปิดตรงไหนก่อนครับ
เปิด
แถวที่ 4 แถวที่ 4 ซ้ายมือโอเคอ่าพี่จิ๊บ
เปิดแถวที่ 4 สายมือ 5 นี้เป็นอะไรครับ
เสื้อกันหนาวหรือเปล่า 5 เป็นเสื้อกัน
หนาวมีเสื้อกันหนาวอยู่ 155 เสื้อกันหนาว
สีแดงมีเสื้อกันหนาวอยู่ 1  2  3  4  5
มีเสื้อกันหนาว 5 ตัวนะครับอ่าโอเคดัง
นั้นเหลืออีกรูปสุดท้ายตรงก็ต้องเป็นเลข
อะไรครับเลข 5
อ้าวต้องเป็นเลข 5 นะครับเดี๋ยวเพียงตี้
เปิดมาต้องเป็นเลข 5 นะถ้าไม่ใช่เลข 5
เป็นเลข 5 มันเป็นเลข 5 ไม่ใช่เลข 5 แสดง
ว่าพี่อาร์ตี้ผิด
เป็นเลขหน้าครับถูกต้องครับโอเคอ้าวันนี้
ได้นักเรียนได้รู้จักอะไรกันบ้างเดี๋ยว
พี่ตี้อ้าเปิดให้ดูรู้จักมีอะไรครับผ้า
พันคอ
ผืนครับ 2 ผืน 2 ผืนโอเคต่อไปเป็น
หมวกหมวกมะม่วงกี่ใบครับหมวก 8 ใบ 8 ใบ
โอเครูปต่อไปอาจเป็นนี้อะไรครับร่มร่ม
หน้าร่มกี่คันครับลง 3 คัน 3 คันน่ะโอเค
ต่อไปเป็นอ่ะมีกล้วยด้วยอ่ากล้วยกี่ผล
ครับกล้วย 6 ผล 6 ผลอ่ะโอเคต่อไปเดี๋ยวนะ
มีอะไรอีกหน้ามีอันนี้แปรงสีฟันนะฮะ
แป้งสีฟันกี่อันครับแปรงสีฟัน 9 อันเจ้า
หั่นโอเคและรูปสุดท้ายเป็น
เสื้อกันหนาวเสื้อกันหนาวอ่ะเสื้อกันหนาว
กี่ตัวครับ 5 ตัวค่ะ 5 ตัวโอเค
มีก็คือทั้งหมดของวันนี้นะครับอ่าได้เล่น
เกมสนุกเลยนะครับแล้วเดี๋ยวคราวหน้าหน้า
เรากลับมาเจอกันใหม่มาเจอกับพี่อาร์ตี้
กับน้องเรียนในช่องคอมพลีเมนสตัลไทยกัน
ใหม่วันนี้ใจค่ะหมดเวลาหมดเวลาแล้วครับ
อ่ะเฮียตีแล้วก็นักเรียมลาไปก่อนครับ 5
สวัสดีครับนักเรียนนะครับค่าที่สวัสดี
ครับน้าดีเยี่ยมบ๊ายบายบ๊ายบายน